- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour à tous.
Bienvenue dans "Parlement hebdo".
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour,
François-Noël Buffet.
Vous êtes sénateur du Rhône et
président de la commission des
lois.
- Alexandre Poussart: Cette
semaine, la réforme des retraites
a été adoptée après le rejet in
extremis d'une motion de censure
du gouvernement.
Cet épisode ouvre une crise
politique pour la majorité
présidentielle.
Malgré l'adoption du texte, la
mobilisation sociale se poursuit.
Jeudi, entre 1 million et 3
millions de personnes ont
manifesté partout en France.
Dans ce climat social tendu,
l'examen du projet de loi
immigration a été reporté.
Il devait être débattu la semaine
prochaine au Sénat.
- Kathia Gilder: Le gouvernement a
échappé de près à la motion de
censure, à neuf voix près.
La réforme des retraites est
considérée comme adoptée.
Elle est désormais devant le
Conseil constitutionnel.
Mais les oppositions n'ont pas dit
leur dernier mot.
Le bras de fer se poursuit.
Emmanuel Macron reste droit dans
ses bottes.
Je vous propose de revoir la
séquence qui a marqué l'Assemblée
nationale cette semaine.
- La motion de censure n'est pas
adoptée.
- A neuf voix près, le
gouvernement d'Elisabeth Borne est
sauvé, de justesse.
278 députés ont voté la motion de
censure, dont 19 frondeurs à
droite.
Immédiatement, l'opposition
dénonce une victoire.
- Qui peut croire que l'on va
mettre la poussière sous le tapis
encore longtemps?
Ce texte est profondément
empoisonné.
- C'est pourquoi la solution est
la démission de la Première
ministre.
- On ne peut pas faire autrement
que présenter aux Français un
nouveau gouvernement...
- Lundi, Charles de Courson défend
la motion transpartisane.
Le député LIOT dénonce un passage
en force du gouvernement.
- Le courage, le respect des
institutions, le respect, cela
aurait dû conduire au vote.
Vous auriez perdu ce vote, mais
c'est la règle, en démocratie.
- Vous direz aux Français quel est
le gouvernement alternatif!
Avec Marine Le Pen à Bercy!
Avec Mathilde Panot!
- Les deux motions de censure sont
rejetées.
La réforme des retraites est donc
adoptée.
- Madame la Première ministre,
vous allez céder.
Passer en force contre le peuple,
les syndicats et le Parlement
relève de la folie.
- Hier soir, votre violence
verbale a débordé dans la rue.
Il faut respecter le résultat des
votes dans les urnes et notre
démocratie!
- Après son adoption au Parlement,
la réforme des retraites est
désormais sur la table du Conseil
constitutionnel.
- Kathia Gilder: François-Noël
Buffet, avec cette séquence, et la
nouvelle mobilisation importante
de ce jeudi, est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si Emmanuel
Macron est encore en mesure de
diriger correctement le pays?
- François-Noël Buffet: A ce
stade, je pense que la réponse est
oui.
La question est moins la manière
dont il va falloir trouver des
solutions pour sortir de cette
situation de crise.
Car nous sommes dans une situation
de crise.
Le travail parlementaire a été
fait.
Les débats ont eu lieu.
Il y a eu du temps consacré et
beaucoup de choses qui ont été
faites.
- Kathia Gilder: Mais un 49.3,
alors qu'il y avait une autre voie
possible, celle d'aller au vote...
- François-Noël Buffet: Le choix
du 49.3 ne relève pas du
Parlement, mais de l'exécutif, qui
a fait ce choix.
Nous aurions pu avoir d'autre
débats.
Les plus belles plaidoiries sont
celles que l'on fait après
l'audience.
Ce qu'il y a de certain, c'est que
le climat de tension est très
fort.
Les manifestations ont été très
fortes, hier.
Les chiffres ont tendance à
varier.
J'ai tendance à croire les
chiffres du ministère de
l'Intérieur.
Je suis dubitatif sur les 3,5
millions de personnes.
Ce qui est beaucoup plus grave,
c'est les violences.
On va y revenir.
Le système parlementaire, pour ce
qui concerne le Sénat, je pense
qu'il a fonctionné.
Il y a une responsabilité d'un
certain nombre de groupes
politiques.
Quand vous avez, à l'Assemblée
nationale, pas au Sénat...
Je vise la NUPES.
Elle tient des propos d'une
violence et d'une telle nature...
Les comportements sont
inacceptables.
Il faut être respectueux des
électeurs et des institutions.
Cela crée aussi un climat
délétère.
C'est dangereux pour le système.
Cette dangerosité, espérons que ce
ne soit pas un objectif politique.
- Alexandre Poussart: Un mot sur
le gouvernement.
Il est passé à neuf voix près de
la censure.
Est-ce qu'il est encore en
position de diriger le pays?
Est-ce qu'il faut un remaniement?
- François-Noël Buffet: La censure
a été évitée à peu de voix près,
effectivement.
Cela montre qu'il y a, si ce n'est
une fragilité, au moins une forme
d'inquiétude.
Est-ce que le gouvernement doit
continuer?
Je ne vais pas me défausser.
C'est à l'initiative du président
de la République.
Mais on attend une prise de
hauteur suffisante et une décision
suffisamment forte pour montrer
qu'il comprend et qu'il entend.
Une position rigide contre ceux
qui organisent le désordre est
nécessaire.
Il faut prendre une mesure forte.
Peut-être que cela passera par une
évolution du gouvernement, le
moment venu.
Mais il faut une mesure forte du
président, c'est certain.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce qu'il
faudrait élargir la majorité?
Cela permettrait à donner à la
majorité relative les voix qui lui
manquent?
- François-Noël Buffet: Le
débauchage individuel est
insupportable.
Nous sommes dans une situation
politique compliqué.
Il y a des gens qui se qualifient
de "républicains".
Nous sommes dans une difficulté
réelle.
Nous n'incarnons pas...
Il faudra construire cela.
Est-ce que les circonstances
actuelles font qu'il pourrait y
avoir un accord qui soit clair et
transparent, un peu comme à
l'allemande?
A l'instant où je vous parle, je
ne le crois pas.
Si cette situation devait advenir,
elle ne peut se faire qu'à
condition que les choses soient
parfaitement transparentes de
parti à parti.
Sur un exemple à l'allemande,
comme je l'ai dit.
Le risque serait trop dangereux,
sinon, pour notre pays, pour nos
institutions, pour notre
fonctionnement politique.
Cela risquerait d'amener au
pouvoir des mouvements extrêmes,
que nous ne voulons pas.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Conseil
constitutionnel a été saisi.
Est-ce que vous aussi, vous avez
des doutes sur la
constitutionnalité de cette
réforme?
- François-Noël Buffet: La
procédure a été parfaitement
respectée.
Avant même de l'engager, vous
imaginez bien que les analyses ont
été faites.
Je ne pense pas qu'il y ait de
difficultés sur la procédure qui a
été utilisée.
Je ne crois pas que le Conseil
constitutionnel ait quelque chose
à reprocher de ce point de vue-là.
Les débats ont eu lieu.
Certains regrettent que les débats
aient été corsetés.
Il y a eu des amendements qui ont
visé à gagner du temps.
Il n'y avait rien, sur le fond.
Je pense que la procédure a été
respectée.
Je n'ai pas d'inquiétude.
- Kathia Gilder: La gauche s'est
lancée dans l'organisation d'un
RIP, un référendum d'initiative
partagée.
Elle doit recueillir 4,9 millions
de signatures.
Est-ce que le Sénat laisserait ce
référendum s'organiser?
- François-Noël Buffet: Un texte
doit être déposé au Conseil
constitutionnel.
Il doit constater la régularité du
texte et lancer la procédure.
Si les 4 millions de personnes
sont remplies, il y a plusieurs
hypothèses.
Le Parlement peut se saisir à
nouveau du texte.
Ou alors, on peut aller au bout de
la procédure et le référendum est
organisé.
Comme nous sommes des démocrates,
il faut laisser fonctionner la
procédure.
Elle existe et elle peut se
dérouler.
Il y a une difficulté juridique.
En général, le référendum ne peut
pas avoir lieu quand il y a une
assemblée saisie pour un texte.
Il faut attendre au moins une
année.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le
référendum ne peut être une sortie
de crise?
- François-Noël Buffet: C'est une
hypothèse.
Mais je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit la meilleure.
Pour le coup, pour donner une
réponse politique, je pense qu'on
a besoin d'avoir, de la part des
plus hautes instances de l'Etat,
une prise de hauteur réelle, et
que l'on redéfinisse ce qu'est le
destin collectif des Français.
Les choses viennent de loin.
Depuis longtemps, tout le monde
constate cette fracture de notre
pays, cette communautarisation de
la vie dans tous les sens du
terme.
Tant qu'on n'aura pas fait
ce travail, on ne va pas
y arriver.
- Alexandre Poussart: Emmanuel
Macron a donné une interview.
Il est resté ferme sur ses
positions.
Il a dénoncé les violences qui
émaillent certains cortèges de
manifestants.
On va voir plusieurs réactions.
- En disant que la foule est moins
légitime que les élus, je peux
comprendre le sens.
En infligeant à monsieur Laurent
Berger, le patron de la CFDT, une
sorte de désaveu, je ne pense pas
que cela soit utile.
- Le président assume
l'impopularité du texte.
Il dit qu'il le fait pour les
générations futures.
Il dit qu'il le fait au détriment
des critiques.
Je l'ai trouvé lucide et combatif.
- Arrogance, suffisance,
condescendance, et
irresponsabilités.
Je suis sidéré par ce que j'ai
entendu.
Je suis atterré, quand je pense
aux Français qui vont être
affectés par ce président qui ne
les comprend pas.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron, en restant
inflexible, n'a pas relancé la
mobilisation contre ce texte,
alors que jeudi, il y avait entre
1 million et 3 millions de
personnes dans la rue?
- François-Noël Buffet: Souvent,
la forme est plus importante que
le fond.
Il faut mesurer ses mots et ses
paroles.
Je partage l'avis de Bruno
Retailleau.
Il faut trouver les mots, d'une
part, mais aussi les actes qui
vont permettre de sortir de cette
situation.
On ne peut pas rester dans un
climat de crise aussi fort et, par
ailleurs, utiliser, par des
mouvements qui poursuivent un
autre objectif que le retrait, qui
est la déstabilisation de notre
système.
Je reste convaincu que l'une des
pistes va passer, non pas
seulement par des moyens
techniques, mais par une
redéfinition de ce que nous
voulons pour notre pays et pour
les Français.
Tant que nous n'aurons pas dit ce
que l'on veut pour eux, où on veut
les amener ensemble...
Bien sûr, il peut y avoir des
difficultés.
Mais il faut que chacun puisse se
reconnaître dans un projet
collectif.
Sinon, on ne pourra pas y arriver.
Il faut reposer la question
fondamentale de "qu'est-ce qui
fait sens?"
- Kathia Gilder: En attendant, on
a vu une hausse des violences lors
des toutes dernières
manifestations de ce jeudi.
On a vu le retour des black blocs
et des casseurs.
On a vu des policiers blessés.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe?
Est-ce que le pouvoir public est
toujours aussi démuni face à ces
casseurs qui s'invitent dans les
manifestations?
- François-Noël Buffet: Je
rappelle que les manifestations
sont déclarées.
Vous avez toujours des mouvements
extrémistes qui sont là pour semer
le trouble.
Ils ne viennent pas pour le sujet
des manifestations, mais pour le
plaisir de casser, de brûler, et
d'être violent.
Dans ce cas-là, vous ne pouvez
avoir qu'une réponse de fermeté
absolue.
Ces gens-là doivent être
poursuivis et condamnés.
Ils doivent être mis de côté.
Je ne parle pas des manifestants.
Les syndicats ont plutôt bien tenu
leur affaire.
Cela s'est bien passé.
Cela a été bien organisé.
C'était impeccable.
Mais ces voyous, il n'y a pas une
seule seconde de tolérance à avoir
à leur endroit.
Ils poursuivent l'objectif de tuer
et de blesser nos policiers.
Nos concitoyens, puisque ce sont
aussi nos concitoyens, ils veulent
renverser nos institutions.
C'est inacceptable.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce qu'il
faut de nouveaux outils
législatifs pour contrer ces
casseurs?
- François-Noël Buffet: Est-ce
qu'on est suffisamment équipés
juridiquement, aujourd'hui?
Oui.
A une époque, le président du
groupe, chez nous, avait fait une
proposition contre les black
blocs.
On est suffisamment équipés,
juridiquement.
La réponse n'est pas toujours
juridique.
Elle est d'abord politique.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas mis de
l'huile sur le feu?
Les violences étaient moins
importantes, avant l'utilisation
du 49.3?
- François-Noël Buffet: Parfois,
les mots sont plus importants que
le fond.
- Kathia Gilder: Il n'a pas eu les
bons mots.
- François-Noël Buffet: Il faut
parfois un regard bienveillant sur
nos concitoyens.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce qu'il n'a pas?
- François-Noël Buffet: Je ne sais
pas.
J'ai été maire pendant 20 ans.
Je suis élu au Sénat.
Ma conception de la politique,
c'est que l'on essaie de faire
fonctionner tout le monde
ensemble.
L'honneur de la politique est
d'emmener tout le monde ensemble.
Tout le monde sait que c'est
difficile.
Mais il faut trouver le chemin.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
la doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
est la bonne?
- François-Noël Buffet: Il est
toujours possible,
que dans des mouvements aussi
importants, il puisse y avoir des
comportements individuels
inacceptables.
Les choses doivent alors être
traitées.
Tout le monde a salué, depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois, la
bonne organisation des
manifestations, et le changement
de doctrine au sein des forces de
police.
Au contraire, il faut soutenir nos
forces de police.
Considérer que la doctrine
nouvelle qui a été mise en place
fonctionne mieux qu'avant, c'est
aussi quelque chose qu'il faut
faire.
Ce qui s'est passé il y a
plusieurs années n'est pas ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui.
Je pense que les forces de police
sont parfaitement adaptées.
- Kathia Gilder: Pour l'instant,
on ne voit pas de sortie de crise
possible.
Est-ce que pour vous, l'exécutif
ne mise pas sur le pourrissement
du mouvement social?
- François-Noël Buffet: Avant
toute discussion, il faut déjà
stopper ce climat de violence.
C'est la première chose.
La deuxième chose, c'est qu'il
faut que les partis politiques,
singulièrement à l'Assemblée
nationale, et pour ne pas les
citer, la NUPES, cesse de
fonctionner de la manière dont il
fonctionne, avec les propos de
provocation permanente et prennent
conscience qu'ils sont députés de
la nation et qu'ils devraient
respecter le mandat qui leur a été
confié.
L'attitude des élus est regardée.
Elle peut même être mimée.
Quand un élu est violent, il ne
faut pas s'étonner qu'une partie
de la population fasse pareil.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le projet de
loi immigration a été reporté.
Que va devenir cette loi?
Les explications.
- C'est le premier dommage
collatéral de la réforme des
retraites.
Le texte immigration, pas assez
consensuel pour être voté au
Parlement, a été reporté par
Emmanuel Macron.
- Il y aura plusieurs textes
immigration.
- Initialement prévu en séance au
Sénat dès mardi, ce report a été
demandé par Gérard Larcher.
Le président du Sénat estime que
les conditions ne sont pas réunies
pour débattre sereinement de ce
projet de loi, après la séquence
parlementaire sur les retraites.
- C'est moi qui ai évoqué,
dimanche soir, avec le président,
la nécessité qu'un texte aussi
important devait être examiné dans
des conditions apaisées.
- Gérard Larcher refuse en
revanche un découpage du projet.
Cette méthode, voulue par le
ministre de l'Intérieur,
consisterait à séparer en trois
textes le projet actuel.
Les dispositions plus polémiques
seraient dans une partie.
- Pour la loi de régularisation
qui crée un titre de séjour sur
les métiers en tension, j'imagine
qu'ils vont aller chercher un
appui de la gauche à l'Assemblée
nationale.
Pour un certain nombre de
procédures plus contraignantes,
ils vont aller chercher l'appui de
la droite.
Ca ne peut pas marcher comme ça.
Ils n'auront pas notre soutien sur
ces textes à la découpe.
- Ce sénateur socialiste ne va pas
suivre le gouvernement s'il fait
du découpage de texte.
- Plutôt que de prendre une
nouvelle baigne après les
retraites, ils ont dit qu'il
valait mieux reculer.
Je comprends.
Mais croire que l'on va régler
cette question par des petits
morceaux de textes les uns après
les autres, qu'il s'agisse de
projets de loi ou de proposition
de loi, je dis non.
- Alexandre Poussart: Un mot sur
le report de ce projet de loi
immigration?
Je rappelle que vous êtes le
spécialiste des questions
immigration au Sénat.
C'était plus prudent, de reporter
ce texte?
- François-Noël Buffet: Je crois
que le président du Sénat a bien
fait de demander au président de
reporter ce texte.
L'idée n'est pas de pousser les
feux à tout prix sur un texte
quand le climat général est à la
tension.
D'autant que ce texte va être
clivant.
Je ne dis pas qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire, mais il va être
clivant.
Inutile de rajouter de la tension
supplémentaire.
- Kathia Gilder: Emmanuel Macron a
une idée: il envisage de
saucissonner ce projet de loi en
plusieurs textes.
Il sera adopté par des majorités
différentes.
C'est cohérent?
- François-Noël Buffet: Il ne faut
pas abandonner l'idée du projet.
Je pense qu'il faut le remettre
sur la table.
Il faut légiférer le plus
sereinement possible, sur un sujet
dont nous avons besoin.
C'est absolument nécessaire.
Personne ne peut dire le
contraire.
Il y a un besoin d'évolution.
Pour ce qui me concerne, je
préfère un texte unique.
Je crois que, comme dans toutes
les politiques, il faut avoir une
vision cohérente du système et de
la politique que l'on veut mener.
Il nous manque d'afficher quelle
politique migratoire nous voulons
pour le pays.
Nous avons besoin d'envoyer des
messages à l'étranger.
On a besoin que les Français
comprennent ce que l'on veut
faire.
A partir de là, il faut aller aux
choses très clairement.
Il faut un seul texte.
Je ne doute pas que le président
du Sénat aura les moyens pour
convaincre la Première ministre de
ce qu'il faut faire.
- Alexandre Poussart: Les députés
Les Républicains proposent aussi
un nouveau texte sur
l'immigration.
Ils ne vous ont pas concerté?
- François-Noël Buffet: J'ai lu
ça, effectivement.
Non, je n'ai pas été informé, ni
concerté.
J'ai une proposition de loi depuis
octobre, que j'avais gardé.
Elle a servi à amender le texte
actuel.
On va rester serein, là aussi.
On va faire les choses comme il
faut pour que les choses avancent
correctement.
Ce sujet est grave et important.
Il faut avoir la capacité
de dire les choses simplement
et d'aboutir à des mesures fortes.
Nous en avons besoin.
- Kathia Gilder: Le président a
annoncé qu'il allait réformer en
faisant moins de lois, mais en
prenant des décrets pour modifier
des règlements.
C'est une
manière de contourner le
Parlement?
- François-Noël Buffet: Je vais
proposer une solution.
Sur le fameux article 3 sur la loi
immigration, il suffit de retirer
cet article.
Les préfets pourraient alors
procéder à ce type de
régularisation.
Il faut s'assurer que l'on a pas
un appel d'air considérable.
C'est un premier exemple qui fait
qu'on n'a pas besoin de texte.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous êtes
plutôt d'accord avec cette méthode
de ne pas faire de loi?
- François-Noël Buffet: D'une
façon générale, tout ce qui relève
du règlement doit être traitée par
l'exécutif.
Le législatif doit conserver
l'essence même des choses.
Les lois sont trop bavardes, de
toute façon.
Et nous y contribuons.
- Kathia Gilder: On va se quitter
avec un regard rapide sur les
temps forts de la semaine
prochaine.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi
prochain, la commission d'enquête
du Sénat sur la pénurie des
médicaments va auditionner les
représentants des principaux
laboratoires pharmaceutiques.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'Assemblée,
les députés examinent un texte
symbolique, mais fort.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est la fin
de cette émission.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA